the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
today I want to pick off pick up where
we left off well to remind you where we
left off last time we were watching
videos of crushing things with the
explicit purpose of understanding
material properties so that we can talk
a little bit about radiation damage in
nuclear materials since I got more than
a few requests to say what's all this
nuclear materials it's like the biggest
research field in the department and yet
it's not talked about in 2201 well now
it is so we talked before about all the
different stages in radiation damage
from creation of single defects to
they're clustering into things like
voids or loops and super structures that
have end up having macroscopic effects
on material properties and all of them
is due to the production of crystalline
defects due to irradiation and to
refresh your memory quickly I'm going to
jump ahead to the stress-strain curve
that we were looking at before we
started watching videos of crushing
things to remind you about the different
material properties and what they
actually mean
so anyone remember what we mean by
toughness in relation to this curve
that's right like the amount of energy
it would take to actually cause this
material to fail that's a measure of
toughness how about strength
so remember this curve is stress which
is a force per unit area versus strain
which is an amount of elongation the
strength of the material is how much
stress you can put in until it starts to
either plastically deform or it hits its
UTS ultimate tensile strength where it
will just fail
how about ductility what do we mean by
that either intuitively or on the curve
yeah exactly how much you can stretch it
before it fails indicated by this point
right here the strain to failure would
be a good measure of ductility and
finally stiffness what do you think
stiffness is more of a response function
so it's how much does it deform in
relation to how much stress you put into
it so it's the slope of this part right
here so that's why I want you guys to
know that we mean actually different
physical things by these properties
which will be important to note when we
start to discuss what radiation damage
actually does so the basic mechanism of
radiation damage is like you might
imagine let's say this green particle is
a neutron or a heavy ion or a proton or
an electron or anything anything that's
energetic enough to cause atomic
displacement so as that neutron or
whatever enters it will strike some of
the atoms in this perfect crystal
creating what's called a primary knock
on atom or PKA for short and then that
Neutron and the released PKA will go on
to hit more and more atoms resulting in
what we call a damaged cascade leaving
behind a lot of different types of
defects we talked about these last time
but I'll just refresh your memory a
vacancy is a type of defect that well
it's not really a thing right it's just
the absence of where an atom would have
been but we refer to them as defects of
their own that can diffuse and move
because let's say another atom moved
into the position of this vacancy then
we can say the vacancy kind of moved to
that atomic position there's also
interstitials or atoms where they
shouldn't quite be and this leaves
behind
a whole bunch of damage that we quantify
using a measure called DPA or
displacements per atom it's a simple
measure of how many times has every atom
left it's a lot of site that's it though
it's not actually a unit of damage and
I'll be giving a talk at Mrs the
Materials Research conference tomorrow
railing against this DPA unit because
I'm going to explain this a little bit
right now what is a DPA a DPA measures
the number of times that each atom has
moved out of its original site but it
has nothing to do with how many times it
stays out of its original site because a
lot of those atoms will get knocked away
and then just move right back but the
DPA part only measures what we call the
ballistic stage of radiation damage
let's see if this works just realize I
can jump back to a slide without
inducing epilepsy anything yeah so what
DPA actually measures is how many times
does this process happen how many times
are the atoms get knocked around but it
says nothing about where they end up and
that's the really interesting part about
specifically radiation material science
because let's say one of these
interstitials were then to combine with
one of these vacancies it's like they
were never there even though they were
displaced and would be counted as part
of the DPA or the radiation damage dose
the net effect on the crystal material
is nothing so let's say what really the
DPA is it's a simple formula that I
think you guys may recognize this look
familiar from all of neutronics that
we've been doing it's yet another
reaction rate it's an energy dependent
flux times another type of cross section
that we call the damage displacement
cross section or Sigma D and it's
integrated over your entire energy range
and that's all there is to it so with
what you know in 2201 you can understand
the basic unit of radiation damaged as
you might imagine we've had four
lectures on neutronics so if you can
understand all there is to know about
DPA after for sophomore lectures it's
probably a pretty simple unit you're
right it is what goes into this damage
displacement cross
it's also something that might look a
little familiar is a cross-section that
says what's the probability of some
particle coming in with energy E and
imparting kinetic energy T to another
struck atom that comes right from
remember our treatment I think I've
drawn this probably 50 times now our
hollow cylinder treatment of a charged
particle with charge little ze
interacting with a particle of big
charged Biggs ze at some impact
parameter B that we wanted to know will
for all possible approach paths the area
of this hollow circle or the probability
that this particular approach path is
taken is just the area here 2 pi B DB
with some constants in front of it which
actually is that cross-section what's
the probability that our particle goes
in with energy E and imparts kinetic
energy T it's directly related to that
impact parameter B and this is the same
thing that you're seeing right here you
then multiply by this little function nu
of T which represents the amount of
damage or the number of displacements
done for each one of these reactions and
there are simple models there are mostly
linear models for if a particle comes in
with energy e leaves with energy T how
many displacements happen it's a pretty
simple linear piecewise model and that
fairly well approximates the number of
displacements that happen but I want to
get the idea of DPA versus damage there
are two very different things and
they're often equated much like the
material properties of strength
ductility hardness and toughness are
equated in colloquial speeds but that's
absolutely wrong so our the idea so is
the idea of DPA and radiation damage
because DPA again just measures the
number of times that an atom is
displaced damage is some measure of the
number of messed up atoms at the end of
the game and they operate on very
different timescales it takes
femtoseconds to picoseconds for a damage
cascade to happen so the DPA is all over
in less than a picosecond but it can
take years for those all these different
defects to diffuse to cluster up and to
form these super structures and actually
end up causing the damage that can lead
to material properties and degradation
so what sort of factors would affect the
speed at which these different defects
end up finding each other
what could you vary about a material or
its environment to change the speed of
these atomic diffusion jumps indeed
temperature you're reading off my list
right all the whole list jumped up okay
you got the first one who are you gonna
say okay yeah absolutely temperature
determines diffusivities it also can
change phases or Crystal Oriental
Arrangements like for the case of
anything iron based the dose rate the
rate at which those neutrons come in can
change the rate at which the defects
cluster up chemistry like if you have
solute atoms which I've drawn here you
may have let's say chromium atoms and
iron and the chromium atoms are a little
bit bigger defects may be attracted to
or repelled to those extra solute atoms
changing the way that they interact with
each other and then microstructure
things that are bigger than on the order
of atoms grain boundaries dislocations
all of those defects that we talked
about last time and just to refresh your
memory of what those are we had been
talking about one two zero dimensional
defects like vacancies we spent a while
on dislocations these one-dimensional
defects that other defects can be
attracted to we saw an example of a two
dimensional defect known as a grain
boundary where you can see this line
between different arrangements of atoms
and there can be three-dimensional
defects like inclusions of some separate
face sitting in the material like the
manganese sulphide we found in the al
Couture fusion reactors power rotor and
all of the presence and density of all
those different defects can be quite
strongly influenced let me start that
sentence over
the movement and clustering of those
defects can be quite strongly influenced
by the presence of all those other
defects so again the DPA actually tells
us this part of radiation damage and
that's what we tend to simulate with
these ballistic binary collision
approximation simulations where we just
say like billiard balls how many atoms
knock into each other what it doesn't
tell us is everything else and it's the
stuff that happens here that can tell us
will our materials fail in nuclear
reactors and there's evidence for this
I'm not just ranting against it and no I
am but I'm doing so with evidence
so it's justified so here's a nice
experiment I like to show in every talk
for this case
these folks took pure nickel and put it
in the same reactor at the same
temperature at the same and got the same
amount of swelling all the conditions
were the same same temperature same
material same microstructure same
reactor save Neutron energies just a
different dose rate a 30 percent
difference in the rate at which neutrons
arrived at the nickel and they get the
same result in void swelling what are
those bad things that happens at two and
a half times the DPA which tells us that
there's a very strong dose rate effect
for material damage so if you want to
answer the question well how much dose
does it take to reach three percent
swelling and nickel you can't answer
that question you don't have enough
information even if you say how much
dose does it take with one IV at one of
me V neutrons at 600 Celsius in this one
reactor you can't answer that question
kind of tricky and a lot of the rest of
nuclear materials data look something
like this now I don't want you to worry
about what the AXI say they're not
readable because they're not important
what I do want you to note is what's the
quality of this data set you see would
you be bold enough to draw a trend line
through a single data point
no what about three where it doesn't
actually match up with one of them or is
there any reason why do you think they
made this parabolic instead of a linear
line I can draw a line that would fit
between the error bars of these two
right here
so the trick is doing these experiments
is extremely difficult and expensive so
just throwing something near the MIT
reactor for a month because we did this
we took a few hundred milligrams of
copper aluminum in Dickel threw it in a
near core position of the MIT reactor
and that cost forty thousand dollars and
that did about point zero zero to DPA or
about the dose that you'd receive in a
normal power reactor in one day if you
want to actually say how long will it
take to get materials to the end of
their useful life this tends to be
anywhere from ten DPA in light water
reactors to hundreds of DPA in proposed
fast reactors to 500 DPA for Terra
powers traveling wave reactor now I
don't particularly have let's see what's
five hundred divided by 0.001 and years
to wait for the final answer the best we
can do right now is to stick them in a
reactor called bore sixty in Russia I've
actually been there it's in the very
western edge of Siberia I don't know if
you could call it that in a city called
Dimitrovgrad they have a sodium cooled
fast reactor though for those of you who
are wondering when are advanced reactors
going to be built they are built it's
not in this country not very much but
Russia has got a fleet of sodium cooled
fast reactors that can get you 25 DPA
per year and if your reactor is going to
go to 500 DPA you have to know whether
or not your materials will survive you
have to wait 20 years for the answer
so what investor is gonna be like
alright here's 10 billion dollars but I
can wait 20 years for a return on
investment no I can wait 20 years to
start building the reactor which means
40 years for a return on investment
chances are if someone's got 10 billion
to give they're gonna be dead by the
time they get a return so this is a
no-win proposition so what we really
need to know is what is the full
population of every single type of
defect in an irradiated material that's
what I mean by damage did I show you
guys this movie yet the orange one we've
talked about vacancies in an abstract
sense but this is a movie of one of them
actually moving about on the surface of
germanium so this is a scanning scanning
tunneling microscope image I think
that's what it stands for and
these are atoms on the surface of
germanium and that right there that
darker orange thing moving about is
vacancy diffusion it's actually
happening you can see it in real-time
pretty much yeah yes I think this was
yeah 30 frames a second or so oh then II
way I don't remember exactly but I'd say
that's why I always reference everything
in the presentations encourage you guys
to look it up and then the only reason
these slides aren't off yet is because
they're 300 megabytes and I didn't have
the bandwidth to upload that from my
house so now that I'm on campus I can
get the 300 Meg presentation up there
because it's full of movies what sort of
things could happen to these defects so
radiation produces all these crazy
defects then the DPA description is over
what could happen next
sorry Jared and then yeah material could
crack that would be the worst case
scenario but that is indeed what happens
in the end and I'll show you some
pictures of that actually happened yeah
yep so they could recombine with
different types of defects and
annihilate each other like if you have a
vacancy and an interstitial nearby the
interstitial can plug the hole of the
vacancy in you're left with another
perfect crystal but now what happens if
two vacancies find each other then
you've got the makings of avoid or we
then call it a small vacancy cluster of
two vacancies but it's actually more
stable for these vacancies or
interstitials to find each other and
make these larger defects than it is for
them to sit alone in the crystal
structure so there is a thermodynamic
driving force bringing them together and
then as those defects build up then what
Jared said could happen you could crack
the material because it could get weaker
less ductile less tough weaker is the
opposite of strong and what's the other
one toughness oh and harder actually so
the origins of void swelling I'll start
with the humble vacancy a void is
nothing but a bunch of vacancies or a
pocket of vacuum or gas and a material
and it all has to start with these
entities the
single vacancies as they cluster
together they reach this threshold in
terms of free energy we're putting a few
of them together is not quite
energetically favorable but it's not so
unfavorable that it never happens so
once in a while you'll get a few
vacancies to come together and that
cluster will survive for a little while
all the while you're making more and
more vacancies nearby and if it gets to
a certain size that free energy goes
negative and when the free energy goes
negative it becomes stable on its own
and then that void will simply continue
to grow and grow and grow and so there's
this process of absorption and emission
of defects by larger or smaller void so
if you have a whole bunch of voids near
each other some of them can be emitting
vacancies which can be captured by the
other ones and this is part of why they
don't all just disappear at once they
have finite lifetimes long enough that
you can build them up to the size where
they become stable then this free energy
eventually curves down becomes negative
and then they just stick around and
we've actually seen these clusters or
voids diffusing so it's not like
vacancies alone are the only thing that
moves we've actually seen clusters of
defects diffusing mostly in one
dimension but what you're seeing here is
a TEM or transmission electron
microscope image of one dimensional
diffusion of a vacancy cluster that
little black blob right there is a
pocket of vacuum that's moving back and
forth and if it happens to find another
pocket of vacuum it could then combine
to a bigger pocket becoming a bigger and
bigger void the other problem too is
that most materials generate helium when
you are radiate them with neutrons did
we go over the what's called the N alpha
cross-section does that sound familiar
to anyone all right I'm gonna pull up
Janus like I do pretty much every class
and show you what's going on because
this is an important one to note because
if you a pocket a vacuum is not that
stable but if you get a little bit of
gas to stabilize that pocket of vacuum
then that pressure differential goes
down and that void becomes a
and that bubble is more stable good was
on the last isotope where I was showing
someone the N alpha cross-section how
convenient
so among the millions of cross-sections
that we've gone through there is this
one right here called Z alpha so what
yeah got a clone the screen that's right
Thanks
there we go so there's this one here
called Z alpha which means Neutron comes
in alpha particle goes out alpha
particle is just an ionized helium ion
which very quickly pulls in two
electrons from anywhere else in the
metal and becomes helium gas and this
cross-section is not zero especially at
higher energy starting around two MeV
there is a small but non negligible
chance that a neutron will go in and a
helium atom comes out and those helium
atoms have nowhere to go they find the
easiest place to sit that happens to be
pockets of vacuum voids and what that
actually does is stabilize as those
voids so the curve I showed you back
here this is the case of free energy for
a vacuum pocket avoid and that free
energy gets lower and lower as you start
to fill that void with gas so as the as
the voids filled with gas they become
more and more stable and a lot of
materials generate their own gas so
that's that and they end up forming
these bubbles now you guys remember last
time I showed you a bunch of voids they
looked like diamonds all aligned in the
same direction
what do you see different here they're
not quite circles right but they're kind
of like rounded round edge squares they
are also all pointing in the same
direction if you look carefully at this
one this one the one above it and the
big one over there it's harder to see
for the small ones but for these three
big ones you can see that they're all
rotated in the same direction giving
away the crystal orientation of the
material but the reason that they're
starting to swell up from diamonds into
bubbles is they're full of gas and they
stabilize the voids
you can also get dislocation build up
normally you would have to deform a
material to create and move dislocations
but when you apply radiation you can
just create dislocations I mean look at
that this is kind of cool you've got a
dislocation source right here every one
of those lines you see is a dislocation
and you can see it's spiraling out and
ejecting dislocations from this one
little spot any combination of small
clusters can collapse into dislocations
or the stress induced from a radiating
things can cause more stress that can
move more dislocations you create what's
called this network forest of
dislocations that makes things a lot
harder to deform so let's say I want to
show a couple more videos of this
because it's very clear in some of these
you can actually see along these lines
right here a few different orientations
of dislocations and if you watch like up
here you can see some dislocations
moving and then there's a source that
emits more right there and so all the
time you're creating dislocations that
are being emitted from different places
and colliding with each other the trick
that we didn't talk about yet is when
dislocations from different directions
collide they get stuck and when they get
stuck they can't move and when they
can't move you shift the balance from
slip to fracture which means like Jared
said it's easier to just break something
rather than plastically deform it and
the effects of this are things like
stiffening an increase in the Young's
modulus because if you remove some of
the compliance from the material or make
it stiffer by injecting all sorts of
different defects it takes more stress
to impart the same strain that might not
be a bad thing on its own your materials
get stronger that sounds like a good
thing right not all not always because
it doesn't just come as stiffening but
now from an atomic point of view why
does this stiffening happen anybody have
an idea
I'm gonna jump back to the stress-strain
curve so the stress or the yield stress
of a material is usually defined as this
point right here when you go from
elastic reversible deformation to
irreversible plastic deformation if
something gets stronger it means that
this yield stress goes up and if
something gets stiffer it means the
slope goes up these two tend to happen
at the same time so if something is
stiffer and stronger then the
stress-strain curve would be drawn more
like that and what actually physically
happens at this point this is when
dislocations start to move this location
movement is irreversible you can't just
snap it back when you relieve the stress
and by making something stronger and
stiffer you make it more difficult for
those dislocations to start moving and
you can do that by throwing any defects
in their way and since radiation creates
pretty much any and all defects it's a
great way to stiffen and strengthen the
material so one of the reasons things
get stiffer and stronger is remember
before we showed you that video of
dislocations sliding through material
folks don't remember I'll bring it up
right now so I didn't see a lot of
shaking heads
this one right this one this one right
here so remember before we showed you
the way that dislocations move so ways
that materials can deform without
breaking if you throw anything in its
way
you're gonna make this process a lot
more difficult and all radiation damage
does is throw things in the way so if
you throw absolutely anything in the way
from solute atoms to interstitials to
vacancies all of a sudden it's harder
for that dislocation to move because
some of those bonds are stretched out or
there's a few extra atoms in the way and
you can then start to create what's
called little pinned sections called
jogs let's say a little vacancy moves
over to this dislocation meaning that it
goes up by one atomic position then
you've got pieces of this dislocation
that are not in this preferential slip
plane and they get stuck so all of a
sudden you go from a completely gliding
or what we call Gliss i'll dislocation
to one that's stuck or sessile those are
the actual material science words that
we use and what it lends up leading to
is a strong loss in ductility at the
same time as things get stronger and
stiffer they tend to get much less
ductile so what you're looking at here
are fuel shrouds these are sort of fuel
boxes that surround the fuel pins in a
Russian sodium fast reactor and usually
what you do is you would grab on to this
piece right here and lift up to remove
this fuel from the reactor during
refueling what happened here is they
grabbed that they started to pull and
they heard a little clink and up came
half the fuel box in the fuel stayed
down in the reactor with no way to pull
it out so this is the reason why
radiation damage is such an important
field of study is you might not know
anything has happened until you shut the
reactor down and go to take out the fuel
and realizing you can't because
everything is as brittle as glass this
is actually a talk I saw yesterday we
had ass we had a summer visitor in our
lab from Kazakhstan and most of their
radioactive materials came from this
reactor that shut down in 1999 on one
side of Kazakhstan and they wanted to
transport those materials to the other
side
so they hired the cheapest truck drivers
to go on the bumpiest roads and the
scientists were freaking out because
only they knew that all of the metal
that all those guys thought was gonna be
ductile like metal was more brittle than
glass and any sort of bump would cause
just complete shattering of this metal
and catastrophic release of radioactive
material so this took them let's see I
think Kazakhstan is smaller than the US
so who here's done a cross-country trip
how long did it take you okay how did
you stop along the way yeah okay so this
trip took them 13 days because they went
slow and I don't think the roads in
Kazakhstan are as good as they are and
most of the middle of the country the
coasts are terrible but the middle is
pretty good so this trip went slow
because the scientists said this happens
you should be careful and luckily there
were no problems and no release of
radioactivity it's pretty cool what you
want to happen is for dislocations to
move on the easiest planes and so what i
wanted i've redrawn here is let's say
you've got a bar of some metal some face
centered cubic metal if you pull on it
like this it will actually deform at
about 45 degree angles you might wonder
like why does that happen
but if you look carefully here what's
the closest packed plane of atoms that
you can see it's not this plane normal
to the stress direction it's like this
one or like this one and so you actually
end up getting deformation in what's
called slip planes or the easiest
directions for things to deform and
without going into any of the math or
atomistic sigh just want to show you
some examples pulled out of again the
fusion reactor so this is a piece of
rotor steel from the same alket or rotor
where he found that inclusion we were
pulling it in this direction and look
what formed all of these slip bands at
45 degree angles showing you that just
because you pull in something in one
direction doesn't mean it deforms in
that direction it deforms and little
slices in the direction that
dislocations can move the easiest so
when you actually pull on some
to show you diagrammatically it deforms
something like that you get a mixture of
bending and rotation to make it look
like the bar is bending uniformly
straight but on the micro scale it's not
so this is a pretty slick image of a
single crystal of cadmium being pulled
in this direction and you can actually
see every plane there that's a slip
plane that's a plane where dislocations
have been moving all the way to the
outside of the material which is pretty
cool and this is the process that you
want to happen anything in the way of
those dislocations you don't start
forming these slip bands and you makes
it more preferable that the thing will
just break in fracture to show you some
extreme examples of slip that's when you
have to go in nano
so these are some pillar compression
tests that used a focused ion beam which
we will be using to top off our study of
electron interactions with matter and
ion interactions to take a piece of
metal and carve out a little cylinder
and all they did is smash they came down
come compressively pushed on the
cylinder and look how it deformed not in
the way you might intuitively expect if
you don't know any material science so
it deformed all on 45-degree angles and
very weird compression not actually
weird if you know what's going on
there's lots more neat examples of this
if you don't push too hard you can
actually see these perfectly symmetrical
slip planes at 45-degree angles to the
axis of compression and mean on every
one of these pillars you see this
happening and this is what you want to
happen to nuclear materials because
you're really trying to balance this
between slip and fracture towards the
direction of slip that means that you
can something will deform a little bit
before it just shatters like those
channel boxes from the Russian reactor
any questions on what I said before I go
on to the macro scale properties cool
all right let's get into the real world
stuff what actually causes this
embrittlement well there's a few things
remember we saw videos of those
dislocations in a traffic jam
not then I'll refresh your guy's memory
it's a phenomenon called pileup let's
see there's the traffic jam so you guys
remember this video now from I know it's
been a week but these dislocations are
moving and feeling each other's stress
and so they can't move as easily as they
would want to so you end up with a
phenomenon called pileup
this happens both near other
dislocations and near any other defect
that gets in the way like a grain
boundary so for smaller material for
smaller grain materials you end up with
more of this pileup and they tend to be
a fair bit stronger and a fair bit no
they can be less ductile with some
exceptions I won't say they're always
less ductile but if you put anything in
the way notice this is just says barrier
any other defect can act as a barrier
and this ends up shifting what we call
the ductile to brittle transition
temperature this is the property that
people worry about for reactor pressure
vessels because you would want the
pressure vessel which encases the entire
core of the reactor to always be ductile
in the worst possible situation the
worst possible situation is on the
absolute last day of operation at the
coldest temperature it could possibly be
as you guys know you probably probably
know when you make something colder it
tends to be more brittle so whose frozen
stuff and liquid nitrogen and broken it
before good I'm glad to see a few hands
well what did you guys freeze and break
cool so just like throws a bottle of
Pepto Bismol and shattered it nice that
must have been a fun mess to clean up
yeah what about you Sarah
cool okay and we're able to break the
coin there you go so normally you'd be
able to bend a coin or if it's a 1 yen
coin you can bite through it not when
immersed in liquid nitrogen what about
you Charlie
flowers okay classic so take a rose and
shatter it yeah
all these normally ductile materials
become extremely brittle when they get
colder so to reactor pressure vessels
the problem is they don't get just get
brittle when they get to liquid nitrogen
temperatures at the end of their life
they could be brittle at room
temperature from radiation damage so
there is what's called a ductile to
brittle transition temperature before
pressure vessels irradiated there's
about this 50% line whatever this
temperature was where you have let's say
50 or 10 or zero percent ductility
whatever measure you're using you say
okay we always want to make sure that
it's got a certain amount of energy
absorption capability toughness at a
certain temperature and as you were
radiates that vessel this shifts over
this way and this upper amount of energy
this USC or what we call upper shelf
energy because this looks kind of like a
shelf goes down and what you want to
make sure is that this change in ductile
to brittle transition temperature never
reaches room temperature you might think
oh it's okay reactors run at like 300
Celsius and things are pretty ductile
right there well you usually have to
shut the reactor down once you're done
with it to refuel and if something goes
wrong and there's a pressure spike
you're gonna have a condition called
pressurized thermal shock or pts in that
case you would have a sudden pressure
wave from let's say from steam explosion
or whatever you could have and you want
that vessel to be able to absorb that
energy instead of breaking in half
because if you break in half that's a
radioactive release the way you test
ductile the brittle transition
temperature is what's called a sharpie
impact test it's probably the highest
tech lowest tech test I've seen
you simply hit things with a hammer a
very well calibrated precise hammer let
me pause so you can see what the sample
looks like you have these little bars
with a notch in them the notch is to
make sure that's acts as a stress
concentrator and you know where the
breaks gonna happen so in a sharpie test
you line up this little sample and
you've got actually in your reactors
usually you've got pieces of the
pressure vessel in this form lining the
inside rim of the reactor Pressure
Vessel so every time you refuel your
reactor you take another few of these
out and you hit them with a very well
calibrated hammer and you can measure by
actually turning this dial and letting
the hammer turn it as it moves through
the material you can see how much energy
was absorbed by the material as the
hammer comes back up so it breaks right
through the material in this case it's
in a quenched or brittle condition and
for some reason they have a lot of
footage of the guy standing and not
breathing but what I want to show you is
what actually happens here I didn't make
the video
I just got it there we go so what you
can see is that if the hammer were to
move through air with absolutely no drag
it would come back to the zero position
if the it encounters some resistance
like with a piece of steel in the way it
then measures the amount of energy in
joules that that piece of steel absorbs
from the hammer blow the larger that is
the better and by doing this test at a
number of different temperatures you can
recreate this ductile to brittle
transition temperature curve so they'll
take a few sharpie coupons they will
test them at let's say every 25 Celsius
get a bunch of points draw the line
through the points and decide where is
the material brittle at what temperature
will it become brittle to show you what
something looks like when it's not
brittle the same test is done in what's
called the normalized condition where
you simply heat the steel to a high
temperature relaxing out most of the
defects and bringing back as much of the
perfect crystal structure as possible
which is really good for letting
dislocations move through it so the same
test is done by the same awkward feller
likes to stand there and not breathe
but you'll notice a very different
result of this test doesn't look like it
but if you actually look at how much
energy was absorbed much much higher so
something like 18 times more energy and
you can qualitatively see the difference
between these two conditions by looking
at the fracture surfaces and this is
where it starts to get intuitive
something that's ductile would tear more
like taffy whereas something that's
brittle would cleave or break in half
much more smoothly so these are the two
pieces of metal that we just showed you
the one that absorbed 180 joules by lots
of deformation and the one that absorbed
10 joules by fracture in a brutal way
this is what you want your reactor
vessel to behave like but the problem
with these ductile of brittle transition
temperature curves is this not just this
part that you're worried about it's that
part so even at high temperatures things
get less ductile so it's a combination
of temperature and number of defects and
if either one of these criteria fails if
you become too brittle at low
temperature or your total ductility at
high temperature goes down too much
that's the end of life of your reactor
vessel and this is one of the biggest
problems in life extensions of light
water reactors they were built for 40
years and they originally had licensed
for 40 years how many of you guys have
heard of the license extensions going on
now to 60 or 80 years yeah so a few you
guys I've heard why not run the reactor
longer not build a new one but keep
getting all this clean green cheap
nuclear energy this is why you have to
be absolutely sure that your vessel
their primary containment will survive
and we're not so sure because well we go
we jump to the part of the video that's
got the Sharpie coupons those we ran out
we only plan to put these vessels in
service for 40 years and folks put 40
years worth of these coupons plus some
extras in the reactor vessel now in
order to prove that it's actually safe
to continue operation you have to have
some amount of material to test and say
okay this vessel is still ductile it's
still gonna work what happened what do
you do when you run out of coupons
anyone have any ideas cuz I'm sure the
industry would love to hear him yeah you
could start using material from the
vessel that's actually what I plan to do
too but with some very strong caveats so
if you were to scoop out a piece of the
vessel you then create a stress
concentration in addition reactor vessel
looks like a gigantic forging of really
thick carbon steel with a very thin
liner of stainless steel and this
stainless steel is there to prevent
corrosion from the reactor water that
little that thin like quarter-inch bit
of stainless steel is what actually
saved what could have been one of the
worst nuclear accidents in US history
the davis-besse plant where there was a
crack in the vessel boric acid actually
ate through a whole chunk of the
pressure vessel leaving the stainless
steel intact and it's that little
quarter-inch of stainless steel that
saved the plant but if you were to take
something out from the inside of the
vessel the part that gets the most
damage you'd be taking out some of the
stainless steel which is the problem you
could take a piece out from here maybe
the outside but then you've got a stress
concentrator any sort of chunk that is
missing is where a crack is going to
preferentially form so you would weaken
that vessel by taking a piece out does
anyone else have any ideas yeah
yes a new vessel means a new reactor so
the license for the plant is intimately
tied to the license for the vessel any
other ideas
yeah
that's what they that's what they did
right so that's why these Sharpie
coupons were there but what do we do
about the vessels that we already have
yeah
similar to the status of the ones that's
what they're doing so they're taking
these Sharpie coupons which they're this
is bigger than actual size they break
them so let's say this region's all
garbage and then they cut little mini
Sharpie coupons out of the last piece
and they're putting those back in so
that's absolutely right you just
probably recreated the years worth of
licensing work and ideas and you know in
a class but I actually wanna get back to
Charlie's idea because that's what I
think has to happen is you'd like to be
able to take a piece out from the actual
vessel and run a test on it the only way
to do that is to go nan-oh take the
tiniest tiniest little piece out and
perform some other sort of measurement
so this is the idea that our group has
had in using what's called stored energy
of radiation damage so don't mind
telling you about it even though it's
not like funded or paper did yet because
it's educational and it's cool so every
kind of defect takes energy to create
defects don't just create themselves you
either have to race the temperature of a
material or in our case irradiated and
it's the energy of those incoming
neutrons that bounces around different
atoms and creates all these different
types of defects so those defects are
storing energy in the material and so if
you think about how much energy does it
take to destroy something it would have
to be the energy that it's already
stored plus the energy that you put into
it during the test can reach the failure
energy what if you could measure this
stored energy what if there is a way to
know how many of each of those defects
there actually were in a material we
think there is well we know there is
it's called differential scanning
calorimetry it's a way of measuring the
change in heat capacity of a material
where you take two very small furnaces
you don't have to put this in your notes
by the way this is just for fun you take
two small furnaces put your chunk of
them your material on one and you apply
a lot of heat to both of them and you
look at the difference in the amount of
heat you have to put in to keep the two
at the same temperature so normally you
would get the heat capacity of a
material how much he can extort per
degree Kelvin if this materials got a
bunch of defects already in it then you
should release that defect energy by
heating it and that would take a little
less energy to heat it up but there's a
lot of problems with calorimetry so
we're actually using what's called nano
calorimetry we're doing this process on
nano grams of material and seeing if you
can irradiated measure its stored energy
because if you could then you could take
a tiny little razor blade take out the
smallest sliver of the vessel smaller
than a grain of sand not enough to cause
a crack enough to measure its stored
energy and I want to show you guys what
this process looks like so I'm just
gonna deviate from the actual lecture
and jump to the talk I'm gonna give
tomorrow I think it's more interesting
and more relevant
there we go
I'm gonna skip through some of the stuff
but it's within the last five minutes
I'll try to get through this see if this
is a record it's what we call the
ultimate snipe hunt does anyone here
have been on a snipe hunt
what's a snipe hunt that's right pretty
much this right
they say bang a bunch of sticks get a
bag and go look for Snipes they don't
exist right they actually do
Snipes are real pretty much have to be
British to know it because they hunt
them they're for sport and apparently
they're delicious it's actually where we
get the term sniper because the actual
size of the snipe compared to the sniper
is about that if you could shoot that
bird with a gun you are an expert
marksman and dealer deserve the
delicious and tiny treat that you've
then blown apart with your balloon yeah
exactly so you can you know Rain Bird
dust on whatever meal you've already
prepared that's what I like in finding
these radiation damage defects too
because some experiments have been done
to plot the number of defects versus
their size and as the defects get bigger
the number of them decrease so most
defects are very very small and it turns
out that first of all the resolution of
the screen is kind of funny I think I
know how to fix that clone the screen
and then jump back to presenter mode
that usually that's not what I wanted
that's what I wanted great most of the
defects that caused these reductions in
material properties are too small to see
even in the transmission electron
microscope so I don't have to tell you
this stuff again that I don't like the
DPA I showed you that what we want is
that we took some inspiration directly
from the Manhattan Project luckily I
have an uncle who works at the DuPont
library and DuPont was quite responsible
for the Manhattan Project
so this memo between Eugene Wigner and
Leo's a lard one of whom won the Nobel
Prize the other one probably should have
said hey radiation stores energy by
Neutron collisions like cold working and
a morph ization so we've dug up this
original memo from the 40s and said
let's do this for everything because
every defect has it
unique amount of energy that it stores
in creating it in some different amount
of evey per defect and we've done some
molecular dynamic simulations to show
that this amount of energy stored is
pretty universal when you were radiate
something we predict that it stores
about 2% of its energy and radiation
defects so if you know the number of
neutrons that hit and you know the
amount of energy per Neutron you know
how much you're looking for so you know
what your signal should be and to jump
through to the whole idea of
differential scanning calorimetry it's
like what I drew here but a lot more
legible you simply heat two materials
one of which contains your sample
measure their temperature and look how
much energy it takes between them to
keep them at the same temperature we did
some of these measurements on a piece of
steel from the nuclear reactor and we
got a whole bunch of interesting looking
peaks for the red curve compared to the
blue curve in the on irradiated
conditions so we think there's something
there so we tried a more controlled
experiment a radiating aluminum with
helium ions and the accelerator in
northwest 13 and we were encouraged
because the initial time that we heated
this material we got some stored energy
out of it in some funky spectrum that
might tell us what the defects are the
bad news is we got that with the control
heat too and the really bad news is that
when you normalize all these curves you
get something that you can't tell if I
drew it or my son drew it looks
suspiciously like the sort of doodles
that he does not scientific data and the
problem is that DSC differential
scanning calorimetry induces a lot of
artifacts in the signal that we couldn't
separate from the noise so our solution
was to go nano to use a nano DSC or nano
differential scanning calorimeter that
can heat about 10,000 times faster than
a traditional DSC so you can get your
energy out from smaller materials way
faster than these artifacts can manifest
themselves what we think is gonna happen
is that every one of these Peaks here is
going to correspond to one type of
defect that's released at a certain
temperature and by extrapolating or say
integrating the area under those curves
you get the energy in each type of
defect
and by extrapolating to a zero heating
rate you should know which type of
defect they are and if you know which
defects you have and how many of each
one you know the full defect properties
of the material and you should know its
material properties because we already
know if you have this many dislocations
it's this brittle the question is how
many dislocations so we start off by we
use a different kind of calorimeter it
actually fits on a chip in fact there's
two on a chip there's one that we put
our material on and one as a reference
that we both put in the accelerator beam
and radiates at the same time to control
for that effect and this is what they
actually look like this scale bar here
is 100 microns and that transparent spot
is the little bit of aluminum that we
vapor deposited onto the calorimeter
right there and so the way this process
works is we take our DSC chip we put a
mask over it vaporize some aluminum to
deposit on one of the calorimeter x'
take the mask away and to radiate the
whole thing and then finally put it in
the nano calorimeter and I'll show you
what happens slowed down by a factor of
a thousand that pulse right there that
whole thing just went from zero to 450 C
in a millisecond and the reason it took
a second is because I've slowed down the
video by four thousand times or by a
thousand times and that little pulse of
heat actually released some of the
defect energy we were able to see very
clearly the first time we heated the
sample this extra area corresponds to
some sort of energy release we then
heated that same sample a whole bunch of
times and made sure that it was always
the same which meant we had our fully
relaxed material and it shows some sort
of a trend if you note this data was
taken like two months ago
it's pretty fresh not published yet so
hopefully by the time this video comes
out it will be and we see some sort of
trend between the amount of a radiation
you give and the amount of stored energy
you can get out so this is what we hope
can be used instead of those sharpie
coupons because we can go much much
smaller and just take out tiny pieces of
the vessel and get the same information
as you would from a Sharpie test but on
the nano scale so the question then is
where the
effect fingerprints where are those
individual defects that we were looking
for well I think they're just popping up
right here the reason for that is we
pick the very fast heating rate for our
experiments and doing these sorts of
measurements on other materials shows
that at 10,000 Kelvin per second let me
think about that for a sec 10,000 Kelvin
per second so in a millisecond something
heats up by like 10 K which is
ridiculous yeah something like that
you don't really see any Peaks the UH
the heating is so fast that the defects
don't even have time to find each other
annihilate and release their stored
energy so we need to repeat the
experiments at some lower temperatures
see what the peaks are but if you go too
low you end up getting a lot of noise in
your signal so there's gonna be some
sweet spot that we haven't yet found in
order to see this stored energy so we're
just at the very first experimental
stage of trying to see can we extend
reactor lifetimes
after doing simulations for a year that
probably no one believes until you do an
experiment including me but for now it
actually so shows some sort of a trend
so it's just enough justification for us
to buy one of these nano calorimeter and
start looking for real so if you want to
see now I've taken you from basic
material science to where's the field
going to how do we keep our reactors
running in about two hours I think
that's the most compact introduction to
nuclear materials I can possibly give
you so any questions on what you've seen
today yes I would expect an up that's
the best I can say as far as is it
actually a line is it a curve I am NOT
as brave or stupid as some of the other
folks that will draw an arbitrary shaped
line through a single data point so I'm
not drawing a trend line yet yeah any
other questions yeah
yesterday the assumption that one little
vessel to say oh not at all take a whole
bunch then instead of just doing sharpie
coupons of one place which is what we do
now you can get a map we don't have that
information now but if you take pieces
from all over the vessel then you get an
actual 3d map instead of a single point
of saying all right well we pick what we
think is gonna be the worst condition
how do you know you don't how do you
know for sure you make measurements like
these yeah any other questions yeah
we would expect that a peak would relate
to a certain type of defect reaction
occurring when some type of defect gets
high enough in temperature that it goes
from stuck to mobile and as it moves it
encounters anything else at will in the
material and will react with all the
other defects nearby decimating the
population of that defect and slightly
depressing that of the others and as you
go higher and higher in temperature the
slower and slower defects start to move
yeah that would be awesome but that
vessel is the properties of the vessel
are highly dependent on not just its its
composition but the heat treatment that
went into make it if you heat that
vessel you both remove the radiation
damage and remove the strengthening put
in by the forging and heating process so
you would have is again if you let's say
replace the new vessel the price would
replace a vessel you have a new reactor
if you heat the vessel too much it's no
longer a code stamp vessel pretty tricky
spot that we're in huh but we're trying
to science our way out of it well it's a
couple minutes after I don't want to
keep you longer but I'll open on
Thursday with a little story about how
mass attenuation coefficients can get
you out of apartheid South Africa I'm
serious and then we'll move into dose
and biological effects
you